hello and welcome to Gamespot after dark
I was caught unaware there because I was
reading an email which is something I do
regularly I am your host for more saying
I feel like I haven't been here in
months it's been a while I've been like
two weeks in the past three or four I
feel good to be back and that does yeah
yeah yeah yeah don't get used to it I'm
not interesting
Rosie can you do the work and then I
just follow along to now when I lose
interest I need to look around there was
a period like last week where I was like
I'm just gonna tell Jake to take over
again and I was like he probably doesn't
want that we'll just we'll just share
deals we'll just share do you yeah
exactly
um yes I'm joined by Jake Decker the Pod
father of course hold on can you
reintroduce me as the proud owner of a
steam deck Jake Decker the proud owner
of a steam deck yeah thank you Jake Deca
AKA
now everyone on this podcast has a steam
deck everyone important who loves games
and puts in the effort yeah to ensure
that they're at The Cutting Edge or
video game so they can accurately talk
about their passion for video games has
a steam deck and the biggest Lord of the
Rings fans
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
yes there's like a correlation you know
the concentric circles completely
overlapped for this Lord of the Rings
fan steam deck owner on top of each
other that's how it works yeah uh
Jean-Luc a fellow owner of a steam deck
is also here how are you doing uh I'm
I'm good how are you Tim more
importantly wait how is your steam deck
oh my uh my steam deck is it's great
it's totally not collecting dust because
I haven't used it in like two weeks yeah
I'm using it every day for sure great
love to see it actually there is there
is a game I should totally download on
it and try out that'd be probably pretty
fun I've been playing mine a decent
amount but I don't think I've committed
not since Alden ring have I committed to
like playing a game like multiple hours
in a row I've been like dipping in and
out of things
um but yeah
um I haven't been on for I can't even
remember why I've not been on I don't
know I wasn't I was going to ask are you
are you doing okay you know I'm living
like you know live Bailey with all the
news in the wish news
you know the oh the queen thing
I feel like I have to ask every British
the games for official social uh the
Twitter account was like breaking news
uh whatever whatever and I was like
firstly I was like
uh replied with like uh the only Queen I
bow to bow down to is Queen Annelise of
the wild Bloods
I don't know I can't knock you know I
can't bombed out it's sad for a person
no longer existing you know and they
clearly had family and friends but also
like
you know a multi-year campaign of
pillaging reaping and killing so
whatever yeah you know 96 years too
that's a lot of time a lot of people
don't get to live that long no no it's
true it's true
um yeah but let's get into what we've
been up to
uh Jake what have you been up to you've
been playing something that I played a
bit of as well and you've written in
preview about it as well I've written a
preview of it and I have a video preview
that should go up
later today maybe tomorrow we'll see how
it goes uh but I've been playing
plaguetail requiem which is a game I'm
very excited for uh I really like the
first game I thought the story was great
uh I thought the characters were
wonderful looked great wasn't super wild
about the combat I'm a little
disappointed in the combat stealth side
of plateau Requiem based on what I've
played now I've only played two short
chapters I'm sure you get more stuff you
can use and more abilities and and all
that good stuff but based on that small
section I played I did not really care
for the combat there were moments that
were cool but a lot of it was like okay
part of it though
um it it's hard previewing a story heavy
game especially when you just come in
halfway because it's I have no idea
what's going on and like I said the
thing I'm most excited for is the story
and I don't know a lot of what's going
on
so I I'm excited to find out so I'm
still excited for the game I will play
the game when it comes out but uh it's a
weird game to preview I also feel like
there's been like three or four previews
of this game now like you previewed it
before uh it comes out in a month
um so I don't know the the preview
schedule seems a bit weird heavy yeah
yeah I would say I did run into some
bugs too
um we can kind of touch on that but you
played it too I'm curious what you think
because I feel like it's been it's been
thought about ages since I played the
original
um so my main kind of immediate takeaway
was like it's a beautiful game
um I was playing it on like my PC is
pretty beefy it's got a 30 90 in there
and I had like started playing it with
everything on full and it's like really
really nice looking yeah it's gorgeous
it's like stunning stuff
um everything from like the lighting to
the kind of like the the bloom and the
the god rays and all that kind of stuff
looks really really nice and obviously
it's got a very unique aesthetic as well
that kind of like
um kind of like a French Countryside
look to it that is like yeah with like a
dark fantasy yeah twist to it look it
looks really really nice because of that
um so that like my first kind of
impression was like wow this is really
beautiful and the character models are
super high rares and you know the acting
is great
um so the the other stuff that struck me
was one yeah because it's been a while
since I played it I forgot how weird it
can be like sometimes you're like for
the longest time like my memories of it
were just about these you know these
siblings trying to escape from you know
this this horrible fate they that they
could be dealt um and then there's some
Rats on the way that you're trying to
get then it was a lot of wraps yeah you
know but now it's like
Hugo can
he's got rat scents
I was like what the hell it was just in
the I don't think that was in the last
game was it no me and Jake were trying
to like remember like was that in Alaska
I don't think yeah and I think that also
is a symptom of us dropping in like
middle of the game for two chapters yeah
so Hugo now can use
he's like communing with the rats yeah
so I don't want to I mean it's hard not
to spoil the first one given like what
this preview is but there is a point in
that original game near the end where he
definitely has some sort of uh a
connection a connection yeah with the
rats and the plague so it makes sense in
that sense and now I'm gonna say rat
sense to add more sense to this
um but it's funny you bring up rat sense
because that is actually what it's
called yeah I I when I read it I was
like that that's a joke that's gotta be
a joke not a typo but it is called rat
sense and I can't tell you how tired I
am of these arbitrary in-game Vision
modes that tell me where he is like to
me it feels like
I get it like I I think it's good to be
there and I imagine it's there for
people who may need that extra help but
like I want to be immersed in that world
and I want to like hear soldiers coming
for me I don't want to see them glowing
orange and I think so the thing about
rat sense is I think even
based on the small amount we've played
the fact that it's in there is an
indication of the kind of where the
design for this game is moving you don't
put that kind of ability in there unless
your game is now more stealth focused
right yeah and that wasn't the case with
the original where it was still focused
but it was very simple yeah you're like
throw the stone over here or you know
cause some noise over here to distract
or like just try and skirt around and
reticence is perhaps a little
uh it shows that they're looking to
explore more of the stealth side of it
which is both exciting as someone who
like stealth games are like top online
same with you guys as well right like
you love stealth games so I'm like oh
okay cool let's do it at the same time
like it's really hard to do good good
stuff like really hard so that's one
element of it so I imagine we're going
to be doing a lot more stuff also like
the rat sense didn't feel great it was
functional but the the reason they
didn't feel great to me was like you'd
hold the button down and it's not like
Batman's detective Vision where it's
like you hit it and then immediately
everything around it flips on this is
like you start emanating a kind of like
a light around you and so what happens
is if you just press the button for a
second you basically just light up your
immediate like literally a centimeter
around you so you have to hold the
button down and like Let It kind of
expand out which I guess makes it gives
it some sort of like strategic
consideration but it's also kind of
annoying where it's like every time I
want to just get a quick glance of where
people are at and what they're doing I
have to hold it down and as far as I
remember it's not like one of those ones
where it's like once you've seen them
like the the kind of like uh indication
that they're in that area persists yeah
like it's kind of like voluntarily but
yeah it goes away very quickly so you're
constantly like holding this button down
and like the color of this looks like
yellow piss looking color so you're just
like oh God beautiful looking water now
I'm like looking at this yellow thing
constantly and then um
it shows where enemies are okay whether
I know like go through walls and stuff
like that is there any limitations to
like how you can see them or anything
there's like a limited view like it
doesn't yeah but is that based purely on
like where you are where you are yeah
okay because I when I hear rat sense my
brain thought like oh you're like using
the rat's Vision to see no that's yeah
that's the idea so like the rats are
picking up on the vibrations and the
various other tells that humans in the
world are doing and they're feeding that
information back together
um I thought it'd be kind of cool if it
was like depending where the rats are
located in the area like you could use
Pockets there like maybe that would be
interesting but then you have to give
the player some means of moving
manipulating those rats and that becomes
way more complicated yeah I mean I get
why maybe they went first yeah so I
think that the and then on top of that
like the stealth itself like if it was
like the stealth was awesome and then
that was like an Edition layer which was
like kind of weird great but like this
stealth feels fairly rudimentary as is
um it's kind of like
there was something about the the the AI
which felt a little bit inconsistent at
times like sometimes they were great at
like spotting you like perhaps a bit too
good where like you mentioned it in your
preview but like they looked through
some stuff at one point yeah there was
one part where I was sneaking and I was
hiding behind a ridge and I moved past
the ridge am I too low now sorry I
switched chairs because this one was
squeaky
um I I hid behind a ridge and then I was
like okay I'm gonna move up a little bit
I'm gonna go to the bush and a guy saw
me right through the bush and then just
rushed me and then I was trapped and
died uh which
that seems like a small issue and and to
an extent it is but like when you're on
a roll and when you're trying to get
invested in that world which is
something a game like that kind of does
because it looks so beautiful and then
when a guy sees it sees you through a
bush and that that momentum is just
killed yeah and like when he saw me I
was like okay well I can probably
scavenge this I can hop off this little
Cliff down to this area where he used to
be but I couldn't jump down because it
wasn't like a white like the things you
can climb are labeled white and there
was no white so I couldn't jump down and
it's just one of those very video game
things where it's like I I should be
able to jump but I can't because
I see the seams of this world yeah
um and and yeah that that kind of like
rudimentary stuff was another thing that
I was looking at I was like ah they
haven't quite got a unique kind of like
feel to this yet so enemies were like
very good like sometimes they'd catch me
and sometimes they wouldn't and then
like the the issues from there that kind
of spiral out is like when you get
caught and you're in a
um
you basically it's it felt impossible to
like re-establish stealth if you know
what I mean like once you've been caught
you're caught and everyone knows exactly
where you are it's not like you can run
away break line of sight I didn't feel
like I could anyway because I tried and
I kept failing and there was no one
around but like you've just activated
alert mode and it's just not going away
and if you get cornered you're forced
into combat the combat didn't feel it
was kind of like very jarring in the way
that like the enemy would hit me to
knock me down I would stand up and then
I had like a decision to make where it
was like most of the time it's just like
attack and then you'd fight back and
sometimes like you'd knock them down
again and you can maybe try to run away
or like you can kill him but most of the
time they just killed me and I was like
and you mentioned in your preview like
it reached a point where I was like if I
get caught I'm just restarting this
section which is not great
um to be a place to be yeah so that that
kind of those two things are
concerning to me in a in a way like
gameplay wise and and yeah so but like
in a lot of other ways I was also kind
of like
the other thing I want to talk about was
um so I sent you a message being like
how do I progress in this area and you
were like oh you gotta knock the thing
down
use an item to do it right yeah it was
like so I forget you had to throw a tar
on something so you have to throw
basically you have to use item did you
have to craft that yes so you have to
craft something generally in stealth
games
there isn't always like a crafting
resource mechanic that
um you include that could potentially
gate your progress because if you're a
person who's like very fixated on
stealth you're some people who are
playing stealth games are inclined to
take less risks right if you're an area
full of enemies you you probably you see
like a shiny collectible there the
decision you make is do I go for that
collectible and risk getting stealth for
court and causing problems or do I just
sacrifice that so I can get through yeah
problem in this is I did that where I
was like okay I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna get baited into trying to collect
resources that are like available and
risk exposing myself and getting into
these combat scenarios I'm just going to
focus on stealthing try and get out of
here quietly so no one sees me when I
got to that point where I texted you
about I had no resources to craft the
thing that I do so I was stuck I had no
and then I was like oh I have to now
backtrack
and I was there was and I couldn't like
backtrack pretty far yeah intersection
yeah it locks you off so I was basically
stuck in this area with no way to
progress yeah because I had no resources
which is like
I feel like those that stealth element
and then like using resources collecting
and using resources
um is like at odds maybe early in the
game they explained to you like hey you
need to grab this stuff or like you
build the memory or knowledge through it
by playing through the first few
chapters but so this could be like a
symptom of us dropping halfway through
yeah again I I definitely think that's
part of it because
there you have a lot at your disposal at
the beginning but I didn't really know
what a lot of that stuff did I knew it
some of it did because I played the
previous game but it was years ago
um but but it was hard for me to like
understand the usefulness of certain
things like that puzzle in particular I
had all of this stuff and I to craft
that I just didn't know what I was
supposed to do I didn't know that tar
um made fire bigger I don't remember if
that was in the original game it could
have been but I didn't remember and
there was nothing telling me so I think
that in particular for me was just a
symptom of jumping in halfway and being
like all right that was the clue to this
puzzle there weren't really any tips
um for it which generally I like you
know I don't like it when a puzzle gets
spoiled through tips but also I need to
know what I'm working with in order to
get through some of these pieces but
like and then the combat scenario in
that thing that we use that I did and
you did um was you get to control the
horde of rats as Hugo and like
send this wave of rats to eat enemies
and and kind of clear a room that way
which is like an interesting new
mechanic but like at this stage felt
just kind of like like a novelty like
you just send the rap to the thing yeah
they didn't really stand a chance there
was nothing yeah so the the section
after that I thought was a little more
interesting because there was a lot more
guards you could use the rats but you
had to use them carefully because the
some guards were carrying torches and if
they have torches you can't get to them
some guards would be near fire so you'd
have to like gotcha you'd have to like
extinguish the fire and then send the
rats in and that was cool I enjoyed that
but the bug I ran into there was I
couldn't Crouch like I swapped my
controller I uh check the key bindings
went from mouse and keyboard and and I
just couldn't Crouch so people would
just see me Reloaded The save still
happening what ultimately did it was I
just restarted the demo yeah
um or restarted that that chapter of the
demo and then I was able to get through
um so my guess I don't even want to
speculate but like I I think there's
gonna be some cool moments like cool
level design and like ways you can use
these tools
but the ones they showed off
particularly at the beginning I found
pretty
dull yeah I would say I think like where
like it's kind of interesting because
we're dropped in the middle of the game
I don't know if that's like a kind of a
a build or whatever or a character
Loadout that is like indicative of what
you'll have up on the at that point but
if it is like I wasn't particularly
super excited about what we had there it
was like okay I've got right sense and
I've got I can control rats and I've got
a couple of things but like there's
nothing exciting in their gameplay-wise
you know what I'm saying
um so like the build up if that's like
middle of the game is just gonna be like
okay it's gonna be fairly plain up until
that point and then it doesn't really
get much better but like again we have
to emphasize that this was a preview
build bugs included are like subject we
expect bugs in preview builds and we
kind of like Factor those in it's
probably going to get better we hope
it's going to get better
um but
like you said in your preview the thing
I'm excited about is the narrative the
characters and the world and that's what
really like oh for me elevated the
original playtale absolutely um and
we've got very little taste of that so
worst case scenario is like the game's
kind of plain and isn't particularly
amazing but we get a good story out of
it yeah um that's that's the Hope anyway
and and I will say
some of the some of the character stuff
I did really enjoy especially with Hugo
I liked Hugo in the first game he was a
little whiny uh early on but but I think
it makes sense he's a young kid who's
sick who's being dragged along this
crazy adventure but this one I feel like
he was a bit more playful at least from
what I remember like at the beginning of
the demo there's a part where you can
race him through this field and it looks
stunning and if he beats you he trips on
his face and they share a laugh and he
gets a little annoyed because he fell
but then he finds a feather and he's
like I like feathers more than flowers
now and it's just like it just feels
like this little kids stream of
Consciousness and it's
it's nice in that world because that
world is dark it's it's pretty
depressing it's heavy at times I mean
you played that demo before that preview
where she was just like I'm gonna kill
everyone and put on my Batman voice or
some [ __ ] yeah
so and Hugo wasn't in your section right
no no it was just her in the um I forget
his name Lucas Lucas the two of them so
like I'm I'm really excited for that
Dynamic I I want to see where the story
goes um I don't know if you finished the
demo but I didn't know the reason
they're on that Quest I won't spoil it
but it's they're looking for something
right yeah they're looking for something
but it's for a certain reason it
directly affects you go
um and that made me want to continue and
I'm excited to see where it goes so like
there is also like some smart not smart
but like some interesting things being
done with the narrative and characters
especially the little I played because
there's like a subversion of the first
game where the first game like you said
like he goes you're basically dragging
this kid around and he needs you for
everything and in this one like amicia
is the one one who's like in a rough
spot like she keeps having like she's
injured and she keeps having like these
moments where she's blacking out and
when that happens like Hugo is springing
into action now and he's not like just
like I mean he's gonna help me help me
now he's like I'm gonna help you I'm
gonna figure this stuff out and he's
like pushing her ahead and so it's clear
that they've figured out or they are
trying to like flip the script a bit and
try and do interesting things with it
which is if they get if they like
stealth actions are a downer kind of
indication of where the gameplay might
be that moment and moments like that are
a kind of positive indication of where
the story could go exactly I feel like
it balances out in a in a way where like
I'm still pretty excited about the game
um especially considering that it's one
like the follow-up to a a surprise kind
of hit in a lot of ways sure until like
Ausable Studios
um are still kind of like figuring
things out like they're they're a big
kind of this is that was a big game an
unexpectedly big game for them so it's a
solo Studios isn't it it is yeah yeah um
also did like simulator or at least yeah
um but yeah like so this is a big
opportunity for them as well and I know
and you know they probably want to do
the get it done well so yeah and we'll
see I'm excited to see more of it yeah
as well yeah
um uh John Luke
hello you've been playing
Splatoon Splatoon Splatoon 3 the third
Splatoon Splatoon the third Splatoon the
third
um it's good it's more Splatoon
uh which is uh I have a surprise first
of all I thought they were done I
thought that was it for Splatoon like
two was done yeah and and to be fair
like I feel like
uh some people are probably gonna be a
little frustrated that they are just
making a third one rather than
continually updating to Splatoon 2 and I
there's a part of me that agrees with
that sentiment where it's like in a kind
of current video game landscape like
when it just make sense to update
Splatoon 2 for you know longer and
longer
um of course this is Nintendo we're
talking about who uh loves to like not
follow current trends or follow them way
way too late like this game has like uh
a sort of battle pass called like a
catalog which like feels very like oh we
we gotta have that kind of stuff in here
but then they've also already said that
they're only gonna support the game for
two years and people are like which is
how long they support Splatoon 2 for so
it's like not like it's like less the
amount but people were already kind of
like really like okay yeah it is there's
so many parts of this game that feel
like begrudging on Nintendo's side right
where it's like we'll give you two years
it's very weird but I will say that um
there are a lot of behind the scenes
changes that I do think justify it being
a new release
um as far as like the they've kind of
redone the lobby system uh you can now
actually like run around a space and
practice while you're waiting for a
match
um the friends list is like way easier
to access uh supposedly
the this is like the first Nintendo game
where they're using like a new like
in-house server so it should be like
better uh like a really good online that
was a hard thing for me to judge because
the uh yeah you know test environment
was so limited
um which in general actually kind of
made it like
uh I I mostly was only able to play the
single player because
um
the servers were only online for four
days yeah and only two of those days
they had like scheduled sessions and so
like the other two days I tried to get a
match and I just
could not and I was like all right
whatever so I actually didn't get to
play uh I gotta play a very limited
amount of the actual multiplayer just by
having the game for like a full week
um and instead played a good chunk of
the single player which continues to be
excellent by the way
um is it an actual single player or is
it like training for no no no full-on
like Splatoon I would so Splatoon one
single player felt like
not quite a full campaign but like it
was more than just a training mode it
was like a surprise right right and then
two they kind of built off of it and it
felt more like a proper single player
and then they had that octo expansion
which added all these like interesting
sort of like oh you'll do fun like
challenge stuff
this feels like it's building even
further off of that where you have this
like full campaign with a story where
you're going through these six little uh
kind of like Island sections and
um you have like these traditional
single player Splatoon levels where
you're uh kind of like going through uh
these like platforming sections and
fighting enemies then you'll also have
like a weird one-off where it's like hey
we're gonna give you this very specific
weapon and you have to uh try and like
hit this certain uh like dot that's kind
of like moving around and like that's
like a little challenge or like hey
here's like a paint bucket you need to
cover this entire
um Easter Island head in paint and like
that's the level so like there's a lot
of variety which is really fun uh it
it's really good like I I really really
like the the single player quite a bit
but you've not finished it right I
haven't finished it I think I'm almost
done with it but um uh Steve finished it
and I think he said it took him 10 hours
to finish which sounds about right so
it's it's uh based on where I'm at it's
pretty pretty meaty and there's like
Collectibles you get that um can kind of
go back into
um like different other modes and and uh
there's like these weird uh you'll
you'll find like these logs that like
talk about
um like the the lore of the Splatoon
Universe uh which is really weird and
interesting uh it's major like who asks
for this Vibes but also everyone
apparently asked for this because I'm
into it
they're all I found some surprisingly
in-depth discussions about how the
humans were killed and like theories
about how these squid kids are now in
charge of everything if you want the
answers you gotta play Splatoon three
yeah yeah which is great uh but yeah
like it's it's a really cool single
player mode so I like I highly recommend
people check it out I think that in
itself and I would say like even though
this is more Splatoon the overall
package is like it's great like what
you're getting you're getting you know a
10 hour single player campaign you're
getting
um the you know Turf War which is the
typical Splatoon multiplayer um
I think it's got maps from all three
games
um not every map but like I think like
12 Maps like a good chunk of them they
have all the weapons from the previous
games plus a bunch of new ones there's a
katana you get which is really really
fun to use because it's called splitana
right spitana it also I think it has a
different name as well though I feel
like I've seen two names for it I feel
like I saw a different name than that
yeah I was oh God what review is I
reviewing I was reading a review and the
the writer had pointed out God I should
try to find it um but the writer pointed
out that like this is one of the
first multiplayer games in a while that
feels like a complete package you know
it seems like yeah a lot of times now
when we get new multiplayer games it's
like okay here's a couple maps for you
to start with yeah maybe we'll add
another mode later uh so that that
honestly had me excited more excited for
Splatoon too even though it is more of
the same at least it's like it feels
complete yeah no 100 like if you like
Splatoon and you want like hey I could
go for some more Splatoon it's like you
are getting absolutely bang for your
buck with this package like yeah
multiplayer
um you're getting the uh salmon run the
PVE mode returns this time I actually
forgot that it worked this way but in
Splatoon 2 you could only play it during
like certain times of the day yeah so
now you can just play whenever you want
which is great
um salmon rush salmon run if you only
play at certain times in Splatoon two
there were yeah I totally forgot they
like cycled it in and out as well for a
while right like it was like oh there's
just there's no Simon run for a little
bit and maybe yeah something like that
now you can just play whatever you want
which is great they have a um like a
little weird card mini game that has
like a Tetris sort of vibe to it I
didn't check it out yet but it looked
really weird and interesting
um
they have
um uh like I said they have they have a
battle pass type thing called a catalog
that I guess they will like rotate out
every three months so they're like
Seasons uh with new stuff
most of that is
um based on uh stuff for your locker
which is an interesting thing so
everyone has like a locker there's like
a locker room you can go to and you can
go to your locker and you can basically
put stuff in your locker you can put
like any piece of clothing you own you
can put in your locker you can put your
weapons and you can put like stuff you
find when you're doing the single player
campaign as well as stuff you collect in
the catalog it's purely just a cosmetic
thing it's basically just like I want to
make my locker look cool and and it's
there's a lot of customization like you
get different
um you can get like hooks or racks so
you can like hang the clothes or you can
put like stickers on like the side or on
like the the front of it you can get
different shapes of lockers it's really
interesting it is kind of a weird thing
because it's sort of off to the side and
like you you have to kind of go seek it
out so it feels a little divorced from
everything else like it
um but you can also look at everyone
else's lockers like people that you've
like played magic can you vandalize
other people's looking no sadly not um
that's a bummer so I want to Splat other
people's lockers like I'll admit I had a
lot of fun messing around with my locker
and like customizing it but I do feel
like it's a thing I'm gonna eventually
yeah I get bored of her forget about
um so the fact that most of the catalog
stuff is based around things for the
locker feels weird because I go okay
well once I'm kind of done with the
locker what's the incentive to to like
do the catalog stuff which is sort of
again their their battle pass like we're
rotating it out every three months but
at the same time I would also argue like
I don't think it
needs that hook necessarily like
Splatoon 2 didn't have that hook at all
and it was like fine because you know
just play a bunch of Splatoon you come
back you know every couple weeks for a
Splat fast
um that's the one thing I haven't got to
try is is flat fast uh it's supposed to
be three teams instead of two now so
that sounds really cool and and
interesting chop mustard and
Mayo Mayo there you go yeah
um those are always fun like the the
yeah the versus stuff yeah and they like
redo the The Hub area and like
everyone's like dancing and it's like a
rave happening
um The Hub is cool also it's it's
um much bigger than the other games
um like it feels more like a little like
City Corner that you're kind of like
wandering around
um I'm very excited to see all of the
weird like drawings and like meme stuff
that the kids put in because uh it was
funny Nintendo asked us like hey we'd
really like you to not use that so like
nothing weird to put in there and I was
like all right fine yeah you don't want
people like appearing day one just
surrounded by dongs everywhere it's just
like well you I mean I think Nintendo
filters some of that stuff out but you
would always get it most of it would be
like weird wholesome like kid drawings
or like
uh I think once Among Us got really
popular for a while everything in
Splatoon would be like Among Us memes in
Splatoon 2 which I thought was just
really adorable so I'm like
I've always loved that aspect of
Splatoon and I'm really like happy
they're they keep bringing that forward
and they're that space is so big that I
know there's just gonna be like so many
weird uh things you can see and stuff
and it's cool it's fun um
I'm I'm really excited to play more of
it yeah I'm excited to actually like get
to properly play it like the online with
people and stuff like that I I want to
give um
the ranked mode uh which is called
Anarchy battle I played a little bit of
it but I didn't play much of it in
Splatoon 2 so I kind of want to like get
more into that that is a like
um OverWatch Team Fortress style like
payload thing
um but the nice thing is that like
because Splatoon matches are like really
really short it never drags on too long
the way like an OverWatch match can drag
on sometimes where you're just like I'm
so tired like Splatoon matches three
minutes it's like the perfect length
it's really interesting because
Nintendo really doesn't have many
multiplayer games right like it's either
you play
Splatoon or you play Mario Kart Smash
Bros I guess smash smash you want to
play the least to find the way to play
Smash yeah online and also like I guess
like
switch Sports if you're Jordan and you
still somehow want to play volleyball
online or whatever hey I I sunk a good
amount of bullying like this yeah but
they don't have like a I know you mean
that yeah like a marquee like
multiplayer a bunch of Marquee multiple
experiences like those three the
trifecta of like smash yeah Mario Kart
and now Splatoon are it so it's like the
slim pickings if you're a Nintendo
dedicated player who doesn't play stuff
like fortnite and you want to play
multiplayer that's kind of it so I'm
glad that from that perspective it's
good it's full featured yeah and it has
some longevity
um but yeah I don't know I I downloaded
it I'm excited to play more of it I'm
going to start playing it sorry
um and and yeah see how it goes but I
just know I won't stick with it long
term sure
um I think if however you felt about
Splatoon 2 is probably how you're going
to feel about someone that's pretty much
how I felt about Splatoon like Splatoon
I've always been like oh this is
interesting and different and cool
um but I definitely know people who get
like super into it like you're a super
into Splatoon too oh yeah Will Potter
who used to work with us oh it is a very
Splatoon pervert that I'm like
did an excellent series of uh uh like
tips videos called like economics yeah
are still like all that stuff still
applies so you should go look those up
on our YouTube channel if you want like
Splatoon tips
um yeah it was it was weird because like
Splatoon 2 wasn't different from
Splatoon one for the most part but it
felt fine because it was like Splatoon
one was on the Wii U no one played that
yeah no one played that and also felt
like how did this even get made I know
and the fact that they were like
Splatoon 2 is coming everyone was like
oh they're gonna make this the best game
this is gonna be awesome because like
they finally like it looks like they got
approval for it whereas the first game
felt like they snuck out someone like
tricks another few people on Nintendo to
put it out
um and then Splatoon 2 was great but
like he didn't set the world on fire no
no but but it definitely had a really
big like dedicated audience that played
that game pretty much until the day um
Nintendo stopped supporting it even
after
um it sold a lot too yeah it sold I have
13.3 million units which
is crazy considering the jump between
the first one because obviously it was
on that but I also think a big reason
that was so successful is that came out
in 2017 when there weren't a lot of
switch exclusives
um so I think that helped a lot but I I
wager that's why they're doing a three
is because it's sold it sold so well and
yeah I'm curious to see uh how much this
one will stick around compared to two
since kind of the novelty that wore off
since platoon 2 is probably a lot of
people's first platoons that said I
think people who really like Splatoon
will stick with this and there's a lot
of value in just like because it's a
Nintendo game it's very like
kid-friendly yeah you know so it's like
what are you gonna get your kid are you
gonna get them like Call of Duty Call of
Duty are you gonna get them uh Splatoon
you know and yeah you can they can make
fun drawings and the first voice chat
yeah the fun thing is like for people
who love Splatoon I know we can say this
about games that we love but like a new
entry in Splatoon isn't just a video
game they get to play like it's a whole
like new cultural moment for them like
you know because the original Splatoon
and Splatoon 2 was like important for
people who are into like fan art and
like yeah crafting stuff and like
fashion and that kind of stuff like the
amount of people on Etsy that were
making Splatoon things and like the fan
art the comics that came out the memes
that came out like for a lot of them
this is like a big injection in the arm
so yeah
two two more years of that at the very
least is for them probably like super
excited sure yeah you could argue in the
same way that a lot of kids play
fortnite just more as a social thing to
hang out with their friends like
Splatoon is totally the same thing we're
like some people maybe are really into
the competitiveness of it other people
just want an excuse to you know make
some weird Among Us memes and yeah shoot
something at their friends
sadly
I didn't even play that one obviously
was arms was a weird game was it was it
it was pretty big in Japan wasn't it I
mean
wasn't that why we got that uh arms
character in Smash Smash yeah sure it's
just so big in Japan but
um
um but yeah I don't think I would be
surprised if we get another arms game
yeah arms is like an interesting idea
it's sort of this like what if we take a
fighting game multiplayer and sort of
mix it up with like a punch out kind of
aesthetic like I think we're a normal
idea we're more likely to get a new
punch out than an arms at this point
have you ever played the Wii punch out
it's underrated yeah it's very good yeah
yeah um yeah uh but I don't know
Splatoon 2 Splatoon three sorry it's out
now right it's out Friday Friday this
Friday okay cool well so probably yeah
it'll be tonight yeah I don't know how
Nintendo works but I'd imagine maybe it
comes out at 9 00 PM I think for the
majority of people listening to this it
will be out yeah yeah yeah and you could
probably buy it now because that is not
going down in price
jack up the price on Splatoon 2 how do
you like that I think they made the Octo
expansion a part of the whatever the
Nintendo online expansion pass thing
expansion for Splatoon 3 like another
single player maybe that'd be cool that
would be good yeah maybe that would be
in a two-year
cycle so sure
um I was just trying to think of
anything any other games
on the steam deck to to test out this
wouldn't work I think that's more of a
preview build thing than anything yeah I
mean the the
grenade your previews uh later than mine
but when I played Fred playing a preview
build in the summer it was like
struggling on my very beefy computer so
I was like probably yeah I sat down to
try and I tried to I started Norco
it reads everything as a keyboard mouse
sounds like pressing the trigger to
right click I was just like oh my God
you don't get my loaded up Batman Arkham
Origins on Steam deck it says it
no it says it's not compatible it
totally works fine mostly a lot of games
I like that like I think the other two
Arkham games are fine yeah
um but it did that for Securo initially
it was like I don't know about this man
and I played it I was like it's fine
yeah totally fine yeah
um an elder ring was like that to begin
with as well actually first released the
uh the game the steam deck um I loaded
up Alden ring and there was no official
support and then someone at valve was
probably saw like everyone talking about
Alden ring and like they fast tracked
the support for that and like it was
like a day or two later they were like
officially supporting it and we're like
yeah I bet you officially this point
it's exciting to see patch notes for
games that specifically mentioned like
hey we've improved the functionality on
like you know steam deck like I think
Spider-Man put out like another update
that was like Hey like we fixed this
thing on Steam deck and blah blah and
I'm like that's cool like I'm glad that
developers are at least thinking about
that more yeah because they're realizing
there is an audience and that just adds
extra value by saying like hey game
plays great on the steam deck yeah makes
me want to play it I did play I played a
bunch of not a bunch a little bit of
Streets of Rage on mobile
um
oh that's a great one yeah yeah it's fun
um obviously we did the mobile showcase
swipe and as part of that I wrote in a a
a skit where I'm playing it very loudly
next to Kurt well it's meant to be Lucy
but then Lucy wasn't able to do it and
the whole thing was like them being like
what are you doing so I downloaded
Streets of Rage on the day we were
filming the skit and started playing it
and I was like this is actually really
fun on on mobile like I was playing it
on an iPad Air wow and I started playing
and I was like it looks really nice I
played the original when it came out
obviously yeah and I was like oh this is
portable streets of rages were like a
lot of fun so I I dip in and out of that
and I forget I keep forgetting how fun
it is and how good it feels in that game
to like punch and kick stuff and like
the input stuff so
um great soundtrack yeah great
soundtrack I'm like considering doing
another like I've the beat em up
um taste is back now after playing
um the Ninja Turtles game yeah that game
was recently which is great okay so now
I'm like I could play some more BMR
games and easier as well to just jump
into and jump out of so I played a bunch
of that on um iPad which was good yeah
um but yeah while we're talking about it
the uh the swipe mobile showcase is out
now it's live we streamed it this
morning
um that was fun
um and now you can watch it the archive
on YouTube right yep no all up on
YouTube I think the swipe show was is
one of the only like sort of events like
that that I've actually laughed at like
genuinely like that like what you guys
wrote I thought was really good yeah
yeah I'm glad that yeah that was uh my
goal was like I'm gonna I'm just gonna
lay it out here like
we are we are a triple we are a console
and PC gaming Outlet right like yeah we
all play we play mobile games but people
don't come for us for coverage of mobile
games not not initially and like we have
made a lot of like Headway into mobile
games because mobile games are very
popular we all play them but and if we
if we just left it there and just said
that's why we did it we'd be lying to
you it's because mobile games also make
money and also like there is a kind of
like no one big outlet that does mobile
games because people don't really look
for that stuff so the impetus was to
create a show around mobile games
primarily because that's a space that's
like not really covered that much
especially in like showcase style things
and behind the scenes there's people
like that that are like trying to get
money out of it because it you know
right sponsorships that kind of stuff
but the way we came out when we were
tasked with it it was like
at the very least let's try and make it
entertaining we got lucky in that we got
a few great games to like put in there
like there was a bunch of cool games in
there yes
because I don't play mobile games at all
yeah like after seeing that I was like
okay some of these games I'm actually
gonna check out yeah yeah exactly
there's some fun stuff in here so like
the goal for like me and Lucy wrote it
um and the goal was like at the very
least let's make it kind of entertaining
and funny so if people watch it it's
kind of funny kind of funny exactly
um uh at the very least like if people
watch the entire thing and they're like
every game and they look [ __ ] they can
walk away at least saying at least the
skits or like the the kind of like
presenting parts of it were funny
um so yeah we wrote like I wrote pretty
much me and Lucy wrote pretty much every
word that was said there so like the
Greg's bits were all done by us and the
skits and the post-credits scene where
Tim uh calls up I was like you're
supposed to be like Tim very Tim again
he's from kind of funny it was like more
than up for it he was like hell yeah
let's do this
um but yeah and like as always like
we're super close friends with Greg and
that kind of stuff but like he rolled up
and just completely knocked it out of
the park it's like so he's like the most
professional person oh absolutely it was
unbelievable like he's in our very like
no it's like one take Greg basically
like oh just rolled up and it's easy but
yeah I've done I've like helped produce
a couple of like yeah like sponsored
things that we've done with him for live
streams over the years every time he
comes in Nails it yeah absolutely Nelson
one yeah other shows that you're gone I
was a little bit behind so when I got to
his British personal impression was
around the same time that the queen died
yes yes so this morning
oh so this morning there was a like
quick Panic discussion to think back did
we make any Queen jokes or anything
related to that because I remember
writing in his because I love his
British accent because it sounds just
like it's just crazy and and over the
top and then I was like I don't remember
writing in a queen joke but we should
double check and I quickly looked at the
script and I was like
and he didn't ad-lib anything as well um
into it like he he put his own Flair on
things here and there and like added
some lines here and there
but he didn't add a queen any Queen
banter in there so I was like oh lucky
but we were sweating for a bit did you
see that thing where um is a Mike Mike
minotti yeah he's one of the people who
uh kind of like teased the the Zelda
interact yeah and then he made a tweet
that was like you're not gonna believe
this I'm terrified to say this because
it sounds like no one will believe it
but it sounds like the Nintendo Direct
might be delayed because of the queen
so I'm like which one is super funny
because there's like no way that could
ever be like properly verified yeah
but I'm also picturing like Nintendo
like a bunch of sick jokes about the
queen and they're direct and they were
like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna take
them out yeah well I imagine they don't
want to even risk it I bet you like I I
think it's true
um sure but I do I would love to
speculate about what caused it and I bet
you there's someone there just been like
we talk about Princess Zelda A Lot in
here yeah
princess a lot we should be careful
about that and then someone's just like
you're right I I just love this like
rumor that's been built on another rumor
that was built on another yeah where
it's like it's like yeah I mean I guess
that could happen except we don't
actually know if this Nintendo Direct is
is going to happen then so if they did
delay we'll never [ __ ] know Nintendo
would just be like this is when we've
always planned it yeah yeah it's Tuesday
it's funny yeah but yeah the swap
showcase is out there it's about an hour
long please do give it a watch it's the
first time we've done something like
this like our own showcase we did play
for all stuff like we had a couple of
things there yeah
um kind of a different thing though it
was a different vibe and that one was
like written in in like conjunction with
partner Justin
um over at the mix uh kind of me and him
wrote that this one's like an entirely
Gamespot production top to bottom other
than Greg Miller
um who came in and like everything like
Sean Luke worked on it JQ added
something right nope did absolutely
nothing okay cool I was supposed to but
I you had that last year so like Dave
Klein helped and Lucy helped and Kurt
did a bunch this [ __ ] did stuff Randy
did stuff Kyle did a lot of work oh yeah
um yeah so it seems pretty much everyone
did so we'd love it if you could go and
like
give it a watch toss if you like it even
if you're not if you're not interested
and you don't want to watch it you know
just click it and let it run and click
in click like anyway yeah click like or
just like just put it in a background on
on a phone and just let it play out for
an hour and it will be have it will have
a a good knock-on effect for us yeah but
we'd love to do more and like we'd love
to Branch out from mobile games into
actual like bigger experiences but we
gotta make them do well um this was kind
of like the uh proof of concept for us
sure as always
um yeah so I've been playing a bunch of
mobile games
but also been watching some TV yeah I
have two what you've been watching
well I've been re-watching I I've been
re-watching Breaking Bad okay because I
started watching Better Call Saul but
more I watched uh Lord of the Rings and
I've been watching House of the Dragon
oh nice everyone's watching the fantasy
stuff I'm not watching House of the
Dragon I haven't installed yet no I mean
I guess it makes I I was initially
really surprised how popular it was
because I just assumed that like that
ending was so bad that everyone was just
ready to write it off but I it took it
took a significant amount of energy to
get myself to actually watch it when I
started watching it I'm quite into it I
think the writing is far better than
what we're seeing in Lord of the Rings I
don't think Lord of the Rings is bad I
just think oh really the writing in uh
house of the Dragon feels a lot more
human a lot more personal it's a lot
more interesting to me because it feels
more grounded
that that could be preference though
um but I I will say the thought of
watching another Lord of the Rings or I
mean A Game of Thrones show after how
the last series ended I was like do I
really want to go through it that's how
I fall I was just like yeah um I don't
care I've got like law not Lord of the
Rings uh Game of Thrones PTSD at this
point because like yeah we did many many
years of
we did that for a year and towards the
end it was like
people were like ruthless to us because
we were just doing breakdowns we were
being honest with you guys didn't even
do the final season right uh we did you
did we did the final season oh yeah we
finished that entire thing oh no like
people like we were being honest and if
we said we didn't like an episode people
would [ __ ] on us because we were wrong
and it was great if we said we did like
an episode people would [ __ ] on us and
be like so it was just like classic a
barrage of like hate from every angle
and by the time it was over I was like I
remember watching it and being like not
even feeling emotion just thinking thank
God I don't have to do this anymore so
when it reappeared I'm just like yeah in
in your spot I don't think I'd watch it
and to be honest like
it's it's very hard to at this point to
recommend another Game of Thrones show
just just that that's how I feel as much
as I'm enjoying it I think like
Lord of the Rings is probably the better
bet because
that's weird to compare though but I
mean as far as if we're going based on
fandoms well yeah we can get into that
people are mad about a little bit but
for me it's like a um I think a prequel
for Lord of the Rings I find more
interesting and maybe it's because I
have more personal like investment in
that world than than Game of Thrones but
um I found myself to kind of get into
the rings of power like really enjoying
seeing things like oh you get to see
like Dwarven cities and their Heyday and
you get to see the elvens at like the
height of their kind of you know like
Civilization and and sort of like where
uh
uh uh like the Lord of the Rings books
and movies were like kind of like a
Changing of the Guard and like you had
all these old civilizations kind of
decaying like you're kind of getting to
see them at their height and I think it
adds a lot
um it feels very complimentary to the
um original uh I don't know if House of
the Dragon works that way because it is
I guess like the targaryens at the
height of their yeah Power so this is
entirely for people who don't know what
house of dragon is is entity Target and
stuff right yeah I mean yeah there have
been hints to other houses because they
are involved but the
at least right now the the circle is all
Targaryen and how they interact for the
most part I'm sure they're going to
bring in more characters because that's
what's going to happen as Seasons go but
I will say uh Lord of the Rings looks
absolutely stunning oh yeah how much
they spent like a billion dollars on
that season and it shows
yes it looks so good it looks so
impressive it looks like I'm Blown Away
watching it yeah to be honest like
I'm having a tough time following what's
going on because I'm not big in The Lord
of the Rings I've been meaning to read
the books but you know how that goes
sure but like I am drawn in just because
of how it looks yeah and like the pacing
and just like the the music do you like
it I like it a whole lot I'm really
really and you've seen it right I I've
seen the version and I'm not I'm not as
into it I'm sorry second episode's way
better okay first episode of fields the
thing is like I'm really into it yeah
I'm like I'm super super like I haven't
read the books all the way through I
watched the movies back in the day never
seen the theater only seen the
theatrical cut and I know that's
blasphemy um but like it's like four
hours long bro yeah um I spent the day
and I got halfway through it like a
couple weeks ago I was like I'm gonna
watch these these that's on how you
should do it is you watch them like each
movie you're basically watching six
movies instead of like three each movie
is on two separate discs yeah like gets
to the point where it's like swap discs
and I'm like oh there's like Mass Effect
2 and I had to change this
I'm gonna watch them but I'm gonna go
through HBO Max I think because they are
up on there but like I'm I'm loving it
because it's like almost no pre-built
knowledge needed because this is like a
story about some of that stuff
um and and not entirely focused on it
um but yeah the first episode feels like
a law dump 100 which I don't know like
you know you guys know me I'm all about
law dumps like I it felt like I was
watching Amazon's most expensive vati
video video yeah I'm talking about like
tell me about and you're like yeah yeah
yeah let's do this
um but yeah so like it's setting up some
cool things and I think like I don't
know maybe it's because I'm just primed
to be into it right now like just that
world but like they were mentioning
things like valinor and and these kind
of like factions and races and I was
like oh I want to learn more about that
and I'm like reading Wikia sure like
that
um but like I've had it the second
episode feels a bit more narrative and
character driven okay um and less like
we need to explain the world and dump
all this law yeah it gets a lot into
more like we've established these
characters and we're gonna kind of jump
between like three different main
perspectives and yeah yeah okay I'm
definitely gonna watch the second
episode I mean I was going to anyway but
like I think that was
because you know you've got Lord of the
Rings and House of the Dragon around the
same time and I was more interested in
House of the Dragon just because
I mean the original Game of Thrones some
people don't like it is you just don't
understand who these people are but like
my
what I take away is not so much how
these different how the politics work
it's more about these interpersonal
stories that I'm invested in and I
didn't feel like I was getting that at
all in the first uh episode of you
definitely get a lot more of that in a
second yeah you get a lot more of it but
it's I don't think it's the focus of no
I will say it
feels to me kind of a lot like the Lord
of the Rings movies and the way that it
is presented in the way dialogue is
written like you're right like it has
that kind of like Game of Thrones is a
more like grounded way people talk where
Lord of the Rings has always had a more
flowery kind of like language to it and
I would say like that is applied to both
the the movies the books and then even
the show
um which I find
fascinating how they did a really
amazing job of making it feel very
um like aesthetically consistent to the
movies without trying to just straight
up copy the movies like I look at it and
I'm like this is different it but it
feel it feels like a world it feels like
the same universe but like a couple
thousand years ago where it's like
things are different but like they're
very consistent to it it's also not shot
in 48 frames a second like The Hobbit
trilogy so that's pretty nice because I
don't want to talk about the hobby
Trilogy so I think what you'll get out
of rings of power second episode
obviously we've only seen two episodes
is it's not more about interpersonal
relationships it's feels like
like Game of Thrones is like people
trying to figure out how they can work
together to kind of like get what they
need yeah or stab people yeah it feels
like very like person versus person
family versus family whereas Lord of the
Rings or rings of power is starting to
set up like way grander objectives and
then it's bringing people together who
might share those objectives or might be
able to help each other out in achieving
those objectives and the process of like
unfurling that is them going on a
journey of some sort okay it's like the
the core of like Fellowship obviously is
a fellowship of people knowing that they
need to travel across Middle Earth to
drop this ring in this toilet or
whatever the [ __ ] they're doing over
there and that's why the second episode
feels more like where it's like oh [ __ ]
this is the threat we have this person
over here realizing this is what they
need to do and then these two characters
realizing that they could perhaps do
this and then it's starting to like find
how they can reconcile their objectives
or their purposes and then starting to
like it feels like the building a party
phase of erpg yeah okay cool that's what
rings of power the second episode kind
of like reversal Lord of the Rings where
Lord of the Rings they all started as a
party and then split off this is like
they're all separate and you know that
they're all eventually going to emerge I
kind of like that yeah yeah it
definitely like the way like I described
it like it feels like we're in the party
building phase of an RPG that's the best
part which is the best part because like
you're introducing the characters while
they're motivations how to what is the
the unique story that you need to help
them with to reconcile um or figure out
that so that they then align themselves
with you and there's definitely in
episode two there is definitely an
alignment where people are like we're
going to work together but there's a
story that unfolds to get them to the
point where they're like okay let's do
this together so it is satisfying in
that regard yeah and they're setting up
some good stuff like if you know the
history the show like uh specifically
calibrom board like the stuff they're
yeah with him or I guess if you played
the Lord of the Rings uh uh Shadow of
Mordor series
um yeah from that
um and I was like oh okay they're like
setting up that stuff like him to be a
very tragic figure that I'm really
interested in and yeah now that I'm
thinking about it the episode as well
there's some really cool stuff like
interpersonal stuff with like what's his
name elron Hubbard and uh yeah yeah the
the dwarf yeah oh the scene with his
wife yeah
and like the reason I mentioned this
because like jonic was talking about
like the dialogue is very prosaic there
are some moments where in the first
episode it kind of like it's a not a
roadblock but it's kind of annoying
because you're trying to get your
bearings and everyone's talking like
[ __ ] uh you know talking fantasy
totally Keen character like what are you
talking about because it's mostly elves
at that yeah and like it's just like
you're just trying to get your bearings
but episode two you've got kind of your
bearings and instead that prosaic
dialogue is put towards kind of like
exploring a relationship between two
characters so when they say something
like that is like emotional in that kind
of prosec language it really hits
there's a lot some lines where like
these two friends who haven't seen each
other for a really long time they say
stuff back and forth and it's written
like poetry and it really lands nicely
and it feels heartfelt and it feels good
I think second episode is way stronger
than the first episode I would agree
yeah I see zombie pie here in chat says
I don't know I think I want to watch a
well-written fantasy thing with
interesting characters that isn't a
misery train yeah don't watch House the
dragon then yeah yeah Lord of the Rings
also I think just has a nice survive it
does it actually it does yeah I think
the the half foot stuff definitely helps
that oh to a degree and like it's the
same way like it is in the early hours
of you know being in the Shire with
Bilbo and Frodo and that kind of stuff
although I'll say there is a a uh
orc scene in the second episode it's
that was it's genuine straight up horror
movie that was like yeah like in in a
way that I was like wow like I've never
it's sort of like I don't know like the
orc store is just like cannon fodder you
know they were just like things that
just like all right Aragorn's gonna chop
up 20 of them and leg loss is gonna
shoot five billion of them like infinite
quiver and it didn't count for you he's
gonna count how many he does and then
but this is like this really terrifying
scene yeah one orc and this these like
helpless people that are not used to
fighting and it's because of the
director of that did horror movies
horror movies but like it has a definite
horror movie moment is this genuine like
it's it's quite scary not scary but like
it's tense it's very very very tense
yeah it's something that I've not seen
Lord of the Rings do that I thought was
a really cool like recontextualization
Of Orcs as a threat it made them feel
very scary yeah in a way I don't think
they've ever done before and they are
starting to set up a lot of like the
bigger big picture kind of threats and
it has a it has a this is going to be
sacrilegious to to kind of make that
comparison but it has a like
Voldemort might be coming back vibe to
it with hot the whole oh sure thing
which is like which is kind of like
keeping me interested there's like
question they introduce things that are
like what is that all about with the kid
and the sword and that kind of stuff and
you're like yeah so like they're setting
up enough breadcrumbs to keep it
interesting
um yeah and I'm like excited like I
didn't expect to be excited about a Lord
of the Rings thing like it caught me
complete I was like drawing fan art of a
character the other day just because I
was sitting here and drawing and um uh
the the elf the new Elf character that
they created for this series
specifically oh um who the one with the
in the whatever the lion with the woman
yeah yeah isn't it I forget his name
I'll be honest but he's cool
he's he's great yeah
I like him obviously he's the Lightning
mod for a lot of the the Romans on the
internet who are like elves can't be
colored it can't be black it's just like
Oh shut the [ __ ] up I've got no interest
in in that I have no discussion it's
like it's [ __ ] Orcs And elves and and
magical [ __ ] just shut your God
genuinely outside of even like that
obvious comments that are just like easy
to dismiss because they're just garbage
like I I honestly am really struggling
to understand like
it like like I get if it's like I didn't
really like Lord of the Rings Lord of
the Rings isn't my cup of tea like I
probably don't like this either that's
fine but to me like it's specifically
people being like this is so different
or like it wasn't like this and I was
like this this is different exactly yeah
well this is different and it wasn't
like this is basically them saying these
characters are not the color they should
be and the those right without coming
you know without saying it is dog
whistling
um and those criticisms are coming from
a place of bad faith because they're not
willing to accept that one it's an
interpretation two it's kind of accurate
in terms of interpretation because like
the half foots it's like a black
character played by Lenny Henry who's a
well-known UK actor and comedian that
kind of stuff and like tolkien's texts
say that the half foots were darker of
color than the hobbits etc etc the L
part of it I don't know but I don't
[ __ ] care oh who cares who gives a
[ __ ] but doesn't matter one bit but I
will just say it's someone who loved
Lord of the Rings to me like I think it
absolutely captures the same vibe in
terms of just yeah you know the tone
um the the uh the dialogue the light
comedy aspects that you know the
original movies also had like it's all
there I think it's totally there and
then the other part is obviously a lot
of people being like
why is Galadriel behaving like this why
isn't she like a soft you know damself I
love her in this the fact that she's out
she's awesome like and the second
episode is like her a bit in a big way
it quite focused on her and her like
coming to terms with what she's doing
but she's like out there kicking ass and
people just don't like that one bit they
want to see the dudes doing the cool
things there is a dude doing a cool
thing why can't the the other lady do
the core thing as well it's like oh come
on just get a grip and like sort your
life you can't take that it's like I
find her to be very cool like she's way
cooler temperature I was just like yeah
yeah yeah I think she does a great job
sitting around it being like you know
old Galadriel very much into pretty much
every character
um also say Georgia
um is super into it as well and she has
not seen Lord of the Rings has no
knowledge of Lord of the Rings we were
going to watch the movies before and
then ended up just running out of time
and not doing it and then and
I was kind of talking to you and you
were kind of saying how like oh you
don't really need to know anything about
it going in so I just said all right hey
you just want to watch it we watched it
and she was like yeah I really liked
that that was really really good so I
would say even if you've never cared
about Lord of the Rings it is worth at
least giving a shot because you might
like it because it really doesn't
require any pre-knowledge I think she
just had like one question for me
um and even then it wasn't yeah I don't
know none of it really requires
pre-existing no the only prerequisites
are like liking or being willing to try
out something in the fantasy genre yeah
um that's pretty much it yeah yeah and
then just seeing like does this specific
type of fantasy vibe with you yeah yeah
no because yeah it is kind of its own um
style compared to you know something a
little more gritty uh hard fantasy I am
trying to think of other than Lord of
the Rings which kind of has that element
of it is there any other fancy stuff
that isn't like a major bomber
constantly
um like I can't think of much I mean
like
Harry Potter isn't a bummer by itself
but everything's surrounded Harry Potter
yeah absolutely bummer Dragon Age is a
bummer that that's that Universe the
universe is pretty Grim yeah
yeah I mean I mean if you said Dragon
Age we're going to games Dragon quests
yeah but like sure nothing like Dragon
Quest 11 is like the the most cheery
upbeat I mean there are moments that are
sad yeah that game just puts me in a
good mood yes music those characters
that art that the color
it's good yeah maybe maybe that's where
you go I can't think of any TV shows
that are like certainly not like fantasy
Western live action like if you go into
like anime territory then you get a lot
of like fantasies I think Western they
tend to go more dark unless your account
there's probably some like young adult
series that I don't know of that are
like
super into it Like a Wheel of Time with
Jason or some [ __ ] oh I don't know maybe
uh something like that but yeah I don't
know like I think I think rings of power
is cool I'm excited to watch another
episode this week hopefully I'm uh um
I'm already like to me it's my like I'm
looking forward to it every week now
kind of show just based on those two
episodes I was really really into it and
to be honest I not to say I wasn't like
looking forward to it but I wasn't like
super just like expecting to be into it
yeah because because I you know had my
Lord of the Rings face and yeah you know
moved on in the hobbits uh crushed my
soul and uh eventually I skipped all
those movies I was like I'm good I
watched the original theatrical Lord of
the Rings movies I was like okay cool
done there's two good scenes in those
movies and they all happen in the first
movie and so it's two scenes out of nine
hours yeah yeah it's like that it's the
part where the dwarves sing in Bilbo's
house and it's the part where he does
the riddles in the dark with Gollum and
those are the two really good scenes
genuinely great everything else in this
movies is so mediocre like shockingly
mediocre and
the holiday was like my favorite book as
a kid yeah and I uh think about that
that uh gml does horror version that we
never got and I'm just so sad oh if you
want a good fantasy series that won't
bum you out you should try reading
berserk
don't don't do that don't do that I need
to I need to buy I can read it but don't
yeah I need to pick that up because I
was telling you that I went to the
Japanese bookstore being like all right
let's go into this and they had every
every volume except for one because of
course everyone goes and buys the first
volume and I was like dang especially
around the time when like it's in the
Zeitgeist again that's why you like I
also try to find the first song of
Chainsaw man same problem man they put
the trailers out the trailer looks
banging yeah everywhere chainsaw man one
is gone basically yeah and the same goes
for like berserk is always coming in and
out all the way you know what they did
have their a ton of Jojo there was a
whole cart no surprise just covered in
JoJo volumes and a JoJo shelf and I was
like yeah oh I've been watching
um Stone ocean the second part of stone
ocean oh yeah how's that going ah
I like the show for the most part I I
have some issues with it it feels
like they Simon red Sonos
um I I know it's a
mixed mixed perception of a part I know
some people really love it and other
people are like it's a little weak and
maybe one of the weaker Parts yeah still
good but like for Jojo maybe a little
weaker
um I do feel like the budget of this
this series is is a little less you guys
the the limitations and it feels like
they're doing their best but I can just
tell the budget is like not quite there
right
um that's a shame still good but just
doesn't feel quite as strong as hard the
part that bums me out is the way Netflix
has been like handling it piecemeal
which is like to say uh they just kind
of like dump it out so like they put the
first part of Jojo way back in
um
last year I want to say and they're like
here's first 12 episodes all at once
because we're Netflix and then we're
just gonna not put anything else out and
now you have to wait a whole year to
watch the next 12 episodes which is what
they're doing now and I loaded it back
up and it was clearly not you know like
some shows they kind of take that break
into account and the first episode will
sort of reintroduce you they clearly did
not plan it to be this way like Netflix
decided afterwards so it just goes
straight in and I was like I have no
idea what's going on what is going on
with this and it's it's real so I is it
available to watch anywhere else no
I know and there is a third part too
um
so yeah we're gonna go through this
whole thing again and because like
Netflix has some anime and it's all like
Netflix has good anime but like it's
anime also that is available in
Crunchyroll and for me to like oh sure
crunchyrolled it's like a surprise
because that whole thing is a mess oh
yeah that rap is terrible
I mean like I like Crunchyroll as a
company the app is a no bueno no no the
app is bad
um and they're yeah no I totally they
need to they need to fix that uh but
it's uh I don't know it's like I still
recommend it it's like a JoJo part I'm
you know you guys are you guys will
eventually get there uh at some point in
20 years you know in 20 years and you
you'll you won't have the same issues I
have with it where I'm like but I didn't
even know it came out until like two
days after very low-key like Netflix
just dumped it and and you compare that
to like when golden wind came out and it
was like a huge deal it's like this big
event and like everyone and who watched
Danny was like talking about it and it
was like huge and that energy is just
like not there at all it feels like
Netflix saw that success it was like we
should do that we should get Jojo and
then just said like
oh I guess we'll just yeah on a Tuesday
and maybe tweet about it I guess it
seems like they expected it to do all
the heavy lifting on its own without
putting it without putting any effort or
thought into it they thought oh everyone
loves JoJo we'll just pick this up dump
out whenever we feel like and everyone's
gonna be this excited about it which
isn't the case like yeah
so a lot of work went into yeah making
JoJo get to that point where it's like a
cultural Zeitgeist moment yeah so now
you have all these like frustrated fans
who are like trying to do that work of
being like hey JoJo's out you should pay
attention to it and it's it's really sad
and it just kind of bums me out um but
it's still JoJo it's still good there's
some
[ __ ] real weird stands happening
um
there's uh uh you know what I'm a little
bummed I get why they did it but they um
they didn't go for one of my favorite uh
English translations for one of the um
uh stands there's a stand uh called uh
Limp Biscuit and uh and they went with
Limp Biscuit because they were like well
we don't want to confuse people but the
original English translation was flaccid
pancakes and I was like we could have
had flaccid pancakes
um yeah Fred dust wouldn't have any
issue with that yeah
um yeah there is Foo Fighter um still
but they just call them FF as a
shorthand to get around it yeah
um yeah we're gonna move on to questions
for the week but before we do I texted
you about this but just now no before
ages ago I asked you about this oh um
I've been like re-watching bits of dark
oh yeah yeah have you seen dog no I've
had it recommended to me though so good
I've just been dipping in and out it's
one of those TV shows that has a feel
and a mood it's like the moment you
start watching it you're just like I
have to I have to stay here I have to
see where this is going
um but yeah I've been watching bits of
that like here and there and it's it's
like reignited a desire to rewatch the
whole thing but the creators of the team
behind that show have a new show coming
out hopefully soon so I'm just like I
just wait for that
I'll be fine but Doc is amazing um is
that German yeah yes German and uh it's
clear it's very clear that hideo Kojima
has watched Dark because you watch me
forget about it didn't he yeah because
you watch bits of when you're like
is that death stranding
what's going on like the main character
one of the main characters The Stranger
it just looks like some poor bridges for
a really long time okay that's what
you're telling me yeah kind of it's a
surprise show yeah but it's it's a it's
a bizarre like Sci-Fi show that
just I like I keep thinking about it
constantly it's really good you should
watch it but yeah
let's move on to the question of the
week once again brought you brought to
you by Maria serious minnesot Discord
and the question of the week is out of
all the games you've played which do you
find most challenging this could be due
to skill game subject matter however you
choose to Define challenging
this is an interesting one I think like
using a liberal
kind of like
um definition yeah like Final Fantasy
XIV is very challenging it's challenging
different like understanding it
understanding it and like committing to
it yes and like working your way through
and even like this is one of the most
challenging games because it is like an
uphill struggle to log into that [ __ ]
game for you specifically yeah 100 in 10
hours into that game and I still like
don't really understand it I I'm not
hooked on it so I definitely get where
you're coming from I need to go back to
it at some point but it is just it's
it's a behemoth of a game yeah yeah it's
that one's the one that I struggle with
and it's funny because like it's also
the one that I like you're constantly
being told how amazing it is and like it
feels like you're losing your it feels
like I'm being gaslit by the entire
games industry yeah yeah and I'm just
like I'm trying to understand but I
don't see it and yeah oh it's it's that
one's challenging I think
from that perspective
um what about you guys hmm
I'm trying to think of one that's not
just like it was hard yeah you know the
easy thing to say is like all the from
software right like I mean whatever hey
yeah that [ __ ] final fight in uh
against Asian sword Saint so that was
that was an entire Savage right for one
fight that took like five hours yeah I'm
just gonna do this first time ganichiro
that was rough man oh I remember that
was rough yeah
I think of something the hardest part
still in Sacramento is easily demon of
hatred oh yeah
I beat him once and then I was like I'm
never doing this one again and then I
went back and I did the cheese and now I
just cheese him every single the cheese
so you run around you have you have to
be very careful you run around the edge
and there's like a small break on the on
when you run around there's like two
trees so you have to tuck yourself
behind one of the trees he comes at you
and he like tries to do a move and he
gets stuck there for a bit
um and then you carry on running around
and you know there's like the Watchtower
you have to jump up the Watchtower very
specifically onto the roof and then
there's a very specific angle you run
you have to like run off the roof fall
but you need to activate the jump just
before you fall so that when you like go
down you go up again and then you can
kick off the wall and get onto the roof
of the building that's just like around
the edge of the Arena you go around to
where the demon of hatred is still
standing and he tries to attack you and
falls off the map and dies instantly if
you can get it done
it takes like
30 seconds geez okay yeah because that's
the boss I I just know I don't fight I
choose only I only the hardest part of
choosing him is nailing the jump so like
the when I stream and I do it people are
like all right place your bets how many
how many times is it going to take and
sometimes like 50 times I'm like oh
um but yeah demon of hatred is like and
what sort of demon hatred is doable but
like if you prepare for him and you have
certain like different like ability
umbrella yeah the umbrella helps a lot
yeah I did it once and I was like
whistle I'm good I'm all right yeah I
think it's just it's it's more like the
mental fortitude you need to like
prepare and then you're just like
knowing that it's like this is gonna
take
a while all the other bosses I feel like
you learn a rhythm and with your shirt
of hatred you don't so like at least not
to the same extent you do for the other
bosses so when I replay secure I can get
through those bosses fairly easily now
because I know the Rhythm I know that
dance more or less even a hatred though
is just [ __ ] up it's a bloodborne boss
in yeah a bloodborne
you know I think the last time I did it
it still took me like
45 minutes probably and that was like
after it took me four hours to do it the
first time and I was like I just got to
take a beating in order to get there the
two hottest bosses in that game for most
people are the bosses that kind of Break
The Rules all the behavior patterns of
that game which is like the guardian ape
and the demon of hatred they just like
bloodborne bosses or dogs or like the
balls like the Bulls the balls one's a
tricky one because it's like it's a it's
a thing where it's tricking you you're
trying to avoid the fire on the front
when actually you just need to stand
your ground yeah right carry it and just
make it through
the guardian eight boss when you when
you know how to get through it it's so
much fun that might be one of my
favorite bosses it takes like when you
know what you're doing it takes 10
seconds yeah like literally 10 seconds
like I put a video up of of me beating
it and people were like what the [ __ ]
it's easy
um but yeah that one's that was tricky
uh games but I don't know what other
games are challenging I guess
I I had a one recently actually now that
I remember that I didn't talk about in
I'm playing but like
um immortality like I found that very
challenging oh interesting yeah um yeah
and not because like it was difficult
but I describe immortality as a game
where you're constantly looking for a
needle in a haystack yeah but the
haystack keeps getting bigger yeah
because like the further you get into it
yeah the further you get into it
obviously you're looking for more and
more specific things and there's more
[Music]
I got to the point where I was like I'm
good man
and like it's a shame because like I
started off really high on it like I was
really into yeah especially when you
discover the thing for the first time
you're like oh this is weird and I love
this it's gonna be weird but I got like
I played for like six hours five hours
and I was like I kind of get the story
and I don't care and it was like I
snapped one time where like for the 70th
time I was watching the same video clip
you know where you unlock it and she's
like talking about the Civil War or
something or like the plague and I was
like the way she started it like same
again oh because yeah yeah it was
annoying to me because like I'd unlock
I was in new video clips
and it would do the thing where it's
like oh is it but it's the same but it's
the same old thing I'm like oh [ __ ] it
was like so frustrating because of it
yeah I get why they did that because I
think the idea is like they don't so so
you don't have to be like combed through
each and every clip yeah find the bits
you need yeah that's the unfortunate
thing about the way that game works yeah
but like if you're if you because then
you you like it presents this mystery
where it's like oh you should really try
and figure this out yeah so then my
brain goes oh there's a weird thing here
I'm gonna figure this out and it's in a
comprehensive way and then it
immediately punishes me for adopting
that mentality by making these things
repeat over and over again if you know
what it would be maybe nice if the game
had some sort of way to maybe like
be like hey you know we're not going to
like remove these clips but we're gonna
be like you don't have to go back to
this one and maybe maybe eliminate some
for you to kind of give you more of a
check markers yeah like seeing what you
need to see here that might that might
help solve that problem because I I do
think that's
um I love the game it's definitely gonna
be my top 10 but I think that is a
pretty big flaw of the game I'm more
excited people from I'm more excited to
hear other people talk about it like
it's kind of funny just put our podcast
or in a video talking about how much
Greg talking about how much I'm excited
to watch that and listen to that sure
but like I got to the point where I was
like I don't think this is a story that
this could tell that will make me feel
good about committing more hours to it
because I got part of the way through I
got some of the twists and I started to
understand what was going on and at the
same time none of it made sense to me
yeah and like that didn't feel good
where it was like
I have an idea what's going on
also I don't have an idea of what's
going on but none of those feel good to
me yeah I think I felt the same like I
really enjoyed some of those twists and
those those reveals but I played about
four or five hours and I was like I
think I think I've seen enough of this
game it's also just like
I I scrub through footage all day at
work you know I don't know I don't
necessarily want to go home and do it
it's a weird thing to point out because
I do think the acting is very good A lot
of the characters very very magnetic and
and I'm interested in it but like
okay rewind play wait hold on rewind
rewind slowly though if you're running
too fast you go you won't get the the
thing you know it's just like okay
that's I also found like a few not bugs
but like
mismatches in certain things and wow
interesting and that like I had to tweet
Sam Barlow and be like is this
intentional or not because it's driving
me mad because I something happened
where I was like oh this must be a clue
it must know something it means
something and I messaged and like
tweeted him and he was like that was an
accident I was like well I just wasted a
[ __ ] hour on that so I think it does
bring that out of you and you're just
like yeah yeah I remember that happened
early we're like it's I think it like a
character like stumbled over a line but
it sounded more like an audio glitch and
I was like that means something means
something it means for me it was like
the character said something but the
subtitle was different yes yes no I also
was like that means yeah and I I like I
went back through a bunch of like videos
to see if it like alluded if I could
find other instances of it or if it was
like I've seen that a couple times
especially it comes up but sound bottle
was like very cool about it I was like
I'm sorry I'll fix that really cool I'm
sorry I was like you pay me for played
his new game yeah
um my pick is probably it's kind of
specific but trying to get into Elite
Smash and Super Smash Bros ultimate the
amount of time I've put into that
[ __ ] game trying to get into Elite
smash is a lot
and I have not done it I don't think I
ever will do it at this point I've
gotten close for those of you that don't
know in Super Smash Bros when you play
online there's this
scoring system that doesn't make a lot
of sense but when you win a lot this
number goes up and it like goes to the
millions and the more people who own
smash the higher that number can go and
like there is a threshold where like if
you if you are ranked like 12 million or
something then you get into Elite smash
but you don't actually know you never
know oh the thing so there's there's fan
made site trackers that'll tell you like
which like where people report when they
made it into Elite Smash and then that
will kind of estimate like oh my God
okay if you play this character this is
probably where you're going to be this
is the definition of suffering from
success because the more people buy that
game the hotter it is for you to get
exactly so I didn't give a [ __ ] when
Smash Bros came out I guarantee you if I
try to do this when Smash Bros come out
and I would have gotten in there no
[ __ ] trouble at all because I would
have just crushed the kids who are
playing and I'm like I'm one of the best
here
um but now it is it is impossible
because I mean it's not impossible
do it but like I legitimately made a
like training regimen for myself in
Smash Bros where I was like okay I'm
doing like I'm doing like uh I gotta
practice my like fastball tilts uh my
short hop tilt like all this stuff where
I was just going through these practices
I was doing drills with Bots uh this was
at my previous job where I had more time
uh I got Bowser to like 11 million GSP
and I was like
this is it this is above the threshold
let me the [ __ ] in and it didn't Eric
Andre let me in yeah and it didn't and I
was like okay think I'm done a friend of
mine who like he is better than me but
like not much better than me has like
eight characters in Elite Smash and I
was like you go to hell Jesus so I I've
kind of given up on that aspect but like
I got I got pissed I'd get really pissed
because like what would happen is I'd
win 11 games in a row
maybe not that many I'd win like five or
six games in a row and the number would
go up pretty regularly you know I go
from like
six million to eight million I'm like
okay cool and then I'd lose one and
plummet down to five million I'd be like
to lose my mind oh my God so that's
probably because like that's probably it
for me that was because it's one of
those things where it's like
with Dark Souls with a lot of
challenging games right I can just put
myself to it and I can eventually get
past it I know that this enemy is not
going to get better it's just a matter
of me learning how to react to this but
with Smash Bros it's like
okay now I'm getting paired with like
someone who some of the best players
online and I'm just getting smoked
because
and I can't I can't replay these people
regularly because the way replaying
Works in that and then there's also lag
you have to consider and it's just like
the zombie planet was also smash
Community is kind of bad I say that as
someone who got death threats from
Project M Community yeah there's that
too where it's just like yeah
yeah and like the thing is is like
you'll find someone who's like a pretty
good skill level like like to me and
I'll be like okay you know we're we can
trade wins I barely want but the thing
is is because that rewards like that
doesn't reward you for playing close
games it rewards you for just destroying
people as quickly as you can and moving
on to the next one that people don't
want to rematch you because like I
either I beat you and I don't want to
keep playing because because it was a
close game and I don't want to suffer
that or they'll absolutely smoke you and
they're just gonna keep rematching
because they want to keep raising their
numbers yeah the online on that is a
mess in so many different ways I still
played it still got really frustrated
with it yeah
um but I have given up that part of my
life I think for me it's uh Rhythm games
realizing because I I think I kind of
have like a [ __ ] Rhythm or at least I I
have difficulty with rhythm um
especially when it'll like change up on
you like I just I have a hard time like
adapting
um
so I feel like which rhythm game
specifically are you better at like
Guitar Hero and that than like dancing
all night I'm okay ektar hero because I
I'm I'm decent at Rhythm I feel like I'm
good at Rhythm games when it's stuff
like Guitar Hero Rock Band DJ Hero but
if I play something like dancing all
night or the Miku games yeah I'm like
dog [ __ ] at them no because it's like
the way it kind of like gives you
feedback is different we like the whole
like pop pop pop pop pop that doesn't
work for me at all right it's like when
you press a thing and like the note
happens it feels like way more intuitive
yeah I would agree with that especially
because like rock band it's like you
know there's that like feedback of like
I hit the button and then like the chord
and the song plays where like the
dancing games is just like it just makes
a fault noise yeah and they're dancing
and if anything I kind of find those and
sound effects
are really good at them especially he's
amazing yeah he's amazing and I'm like I
just don't because we went to I think it
was Gamescom or I don't know where it
was I think it was Gamescom and he was I
might have been Paris games a week and
he was playing like the Persona dancing
game and like absolutely killing it oh
yeah I was like
I can't tell Lenny's I'm terrible at
this yeah I'm bad at those I I really
struggle on like certain stages in like
Rhythm Heaven games I love Rhythm Heaven
games but some of those stages like
there's just like certain ones where
It'll like do like a done and then it'll
do like a Dun Dun or something and like
I just no matter how hard I try like I
always yeah [ __ ] those up and there's
loads of those impact on the pathogen as
well which is like the same thing yeah
and and but I keep playing them because
I like do enjoy them like I love uh the
Taiko games because they're so much fun
I really love the like kind of WarioWare
Vibes of like Rhythm Heaven and think
those games are so creative but
boy do I struggle with some of those and
I just it feels like I'll never get
better I'm just like this is just like a
me problem that I cannot overcome that
actually reminds me of another
challenging one which is like
another interpretation of what we find
challenging is like being consistently
good at something that you think you
should be consistently good at sure and
the game that comes to mind for that is
valorant and I guess like Count Strike
because those two games
I guess maybe stuff like I don't play
pubg or anything like I guess you could
try like add those to it but like those
two games specifically they feel like
sports where like yeah some days you
wake up and you're like playing the game
or like playing the sport and you're
like I'm feeling it I'm sinking this
this freeze or I can hitting the ball or
whatever it may be oh yeah yeah you're
in the floor you feel good and it's the
same with like games like vitamin or CS
like you're nailing the headshots you're
making the right decisions you're using
your abilities properly other days like
you wake up and like you've eaten the
wrong thing and you just feel like I
can't land yeah I can't get this ball in
the net I can't and it's the same with
like you're missing your shots like
you're everything and when that happens
like the feeling of being like Oh I know
I can do this I should be able to do
this it's like crushing and it's so
challenging to keep going and at the
same time like you're compelled to play
them because it's like a compulsion like
Valerian is such a hard game to put down
because it feels because when you have
that moment of like you nail a headshot
you feel like King you're like I'm top
of the world like I'm the best gamer and
then like you just get crushed for a
while and you come back the next day
just hoping it's like gambling you're
hoping that you'll hit the jackpot
instead of lose all your money for this
next session
so that can be it's like also like a
mental fortitude kind of check but it's
like do you have it you need to keep
coming back even when you get you're
getting kicked on your ass constantly
yeah but yeah there you have it those
are the games that we find challenging
thank you for sending that
um in and setting that up Maria as
always
and we're going to call it there for the
podcast remember if you want to send us
questions you can email us at
after.podcast gamespot.com or join our
Discord where you can chat with other
people in the Discord including us and
also
take part in the question of the week um
that we just took part in which was uh
created by Maria
um and then let's go to what we're up to
John Luke what are you up to anything
you want to plug where can people find
you uh you can find me answer on like
sepke on Twitter I'm mostly gonna be I
have like
there's a surprising amount of stuff
around uh Tokyo game show next week that
we're going to be covering
um way more so than in previous years
which is uh kind of exciting um so I I
feel like I just have a ton of stuff
around that yeah and I can't get into
specifics of but I'm uh look forward to
that that should be cool yeah Jake
uh my
plague tale preview article went up the
video should be going up tomorrow
morning I think uh we'll see how it goes
it's in feedback now so we'll see if uh
it gets approval uh other than that
I think that's about it one thing I do
want to point out I actually don't think
it's out until next week but I'm very
excited for it is Chris Morris in the UK
is working on a really good show yes
um about like psychology and games and I
believe the first episode goes up soon
yeah soonish
um so I would keep an eye for that it's
really good
um
and then yeah that I just want to point
out because I watched this morning I was
like damn that's good enough it's good
yeah yeah it's been in production yeah
he's been working on working on that
before right he's done a couple of
videos like that so if you've seen those
before
um it's yeah kind of like in that the
scripts have been like coming through
for a while now so I've been like
reading it and like it's come together
super super yeah and Chris is amazing
now you can tell he's like really like
taking his time yeah to get it right
which is great similarly Like Jesse on
the video team has been working on
something that should be coming up soon
so yes a very long time yeah yeah
um but yeah uh I'm at more h on
everything uh go and watch the swipe
show
um I am working on a preview for
something that I can't talk about but
you'll see you tomorrow not tomorrow
next week
um
but yeah that'll be exciting
um
yeah uh and in the meantime uh please
remember to subscribe review if you're
watching on Twitch hit the follow share
it and we're still kind of trying to
grow the twitch presence that we have
here
um and we can only do that if you you
know show up which we appreciate and
also share and follow so
see you next time
bye everyone bye everyone
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]